we got 256 regular season games that are
now set in i don't want to say stone any
other year they'd be set in stone it's
some kind of a thick parchment this year
it feels
permanent but we know that there's the
potential for it to potentially change
we'll talk about that as the day unfolds
for now let's celebrate what we have and
what we have is 256 regular season games
and it starts with week one right out of
the gates big cat i don't know if you
saw the reports there were plenty of
different people suggesting the first
four weeks were going to be all the
inner conference games so they could be
easily trimmed off if need be or moved
to the end of the season the nfl comes
out of the gates with a
a not a bang
an explosion
week one has nine divisional games
that's the most since 1998
and i love the week one slate i'm
fascinated by the week one slate they
held nothing back in the week that you
know they could have given us the 16
worst games of the year whatever they
are and we would have loved it but they
come out swinging with some great games
right out of the gates
yeah it's uh just looking at the
schedule right now i mean it's
it starts i i will say i would love to
hear your take on this but the thursday
night opener obviously it's going to be
the chiefs and we are hoping for a
replay of that texas chiefs playoff game
last year where there was a million
points scored
it's just a little weird to remind
yourself that deandre hopkins is no
longer on the texans changes things a
little bit but i love the the week one
slate as well you have the packers
versus vikings that sunday night game is
going to be great with the cowboys
opening the new stadium in la is going
to be a fantastic thing to watch and
then the double monday night headers
always i wish they did it every single
week because it's great to have two
games and have that late game but that
first game the the the chiefs raising
their banner kicking off the season the
texans going in there it's gonna be
fascinating because even though that was
a uh compelling playoff game last year
and we saw the texans go up with that
big lead and everyone wants to watch
desean watson it's it's the texans feel
like they're teetering right now with
what happened in the off season and
where bill o'brien is going with that
team whereas the chiefs feel like they
didn't they're not going to miss a step
they didn't really lose much and they oh
they added one of the best running backs
in the draft class or the best running
back in the draft class so i feel like
the chiefs are going to have a heck of a
party on that thursday night
probably blow him out
uh but it will be great to have football
back first of all it's easy for you to
say you'd like to have a monday night
double header every week because you
don't have to get up and do this show on
tuesday mornings i can't imagine a
monday night doubleheader i would like
it in theory but i know how tough that
first tuesday is and i know we're not
supposed to complain but i'm telling you
that first tuesday i got nothing left in
the tank because it's the first sunday
in all those games and off we go and
then to have that monday night double
header that lasts until after 1am often
what i end up doing is just taping the
second half of the second game because i
got nothing left by then so it is great
to start with a monday night double
header i am not of all the things i'm
going to lobby for a monday night double
header every week is definitely not one
of them but the idea of the steelers and
the giants two of the nfl's
most well-established franchises family
owned there's so many connections
between the rooneys and the mars and and
the idea that they're you know they get
together once every four years and there
it is boom starting us off on the first
monday night of the year again they
could have held these games back they
didn't have to give us that they could
have given us jaguars titans monday
night football and we'd have been happy
with it right out of the gates because
we want anything now that's what i love
so much about this week one and you
mentioned the opener the texans and the
chiefs and you're right how the
perception of the texans has changed
since deandre hopkins was traded look at
any prop that's out there from a betting
perspective the numbers for the texans
plummeted the moment they traded deandre
hopkins it's amazing
how the lack of hopkins changes
everyone's perception of the texans but
it just does you know maybe they'll be
fine maybe they'll figure it out maybe
brandon cooks will be great but you take
deandre hopkins off of that team and all
of a sudden it's like what the hell do
they have
other than sean
he's one of the best wide receivers in
the nfl i mean he might be uh you if you
wanted to predict where he is in in the
arc of his career he could be on the
other side of the peak the peak being
two years ago but he is still a top five
guy
and that offense watching that offense
you know deshawn watson is a is a
quarterback that keeps a lot of plays
alive and a lot of times when that
happens you need someone like deandre
hopkins who you trust to to not bail you
out but kind of bail you out in those in
those tough situations where everything
breaks down so not having him is going
to be a huge impact and it just takes
away a little the fire power it takes
away a little of maybe the splash of
that opening week i just think the
chiefs
are set up in a position where they
didn't lose
pretty much anything and if if they can
avoid the big you know injury to one of
their key key guys it's gonna be tough
to beat them because they they are that
good when they're healthy and uh if it
weren't for patrick mahomes hurting his
knee last year they probably would have
won a couple more games and we'd be
talking about them starting you know a
long run here
and you know i am fascinated also big
cat by the fact that the
first week of the season
doesn't shy away from
states where right now we would say how
are they going to be able to play games
how are they going to be able to play
games in california well the la stadium
opens with the cowboys and the rams
remember that preseason game when the
rams returned to la when the cowboys
went to the coliseum and it felt like a
super bowl that night i mean you talk
about the cowboys and the rams to
christen that new stadium
pandemic be damned and then the giants
with monday night football hosting and
it's new jersey it's not new york but
still in the sa that area emerged as the
biggest hot spot in the country the idea
that the nfl would plant a flag in new
jersey for week one monday night given
everything that's going on
it's it
i think that that
and and we're seeing a little bits and
pieces of this now and it's starting to
come to light and i wrote about it over
the weekend there is a high level of
confidence behind the curtain that
they're going to get these games in that
the world is going to be dramatically
different you and i communicated about
that over the weekend the world is going
to be dramatically different come august
september than it is now and it's hard
to get our brains around it now but i
think this schedule especially the way
week one is constructed
is the nfl's way of saying hey folks it
may not look like it now it may not feel
like it now but by the time we get to
labor day
we have a feeling and we have reason to
have that feeling that things are going
to be a hell of a lot different and a
hell of a lot better than they are now
and i appreciate that optimistic view
from the nfl because
there there does there has been points
in the last month and a half where it
feels like
nothing's ever gonna get back to normal
and nothing's ever go you know sports
aren't gonna come back we're not gonna
be able to go back to our regular lives
and i'm all for following every single
guideline but it is nice to see
at least the optimistic view of the nfl
is not saying right now we are playing
100
but they're saying we're going to plan
like we're going to play because we're
going to hope that everything works out
and falls in a row here leading up to it
where we can get you know players back
and possibly even fans in the stands
yeah and look i i still don't rule out
the possibility of open stadiums i know
some comments from gavin newsom the
governor of california yesterday threw a
little water on that concept just to
water on the concept of nfl teams
playing at all we're going to talk about
that later in the program but part of
that optimism that i picked up very
clearly last week talking to people who
know what's going on talking to people
who understand the medical and the
scientific aspect of the pandemic the
explosion that is anticipated in
diagnostic testing and antibody testing
that is the key these tests are going to
be falling off the trees come august
people are going to know if they want to
know every day am i positive it's going
to be easy to take a test and know have
i had it
and and also understanding what it means
to have the antibody by september we'll
know a lot more than what we know now
there will be so many ways that we can
constantly check and i feel like it's
going to be part of our routine like
shaving although you don't shave often
enough to relate i shave every day
although you've shaved recently but you
know it's just going to be part of what
we do
a quick you know every morning every
night a quick
coronavirus test especially if we've
been out anywhere if you stay home you
don't need to do it every day if you go
out and about
am i positive am i positive and you keep
getting that that you know go to a game
come home am i positive am i negative
and and i think that's just going to be
our reality when you look at how much
our reality has changed the last six
weeks it's not all that hard to envision
a dramatic change you know in a good way
in a good way a way to exist to co-exist
with this virus that's what they think
is coming and i'm not saying it's
specifically going to be like that where
it is like you shave you brush your
teeth you do a coronavirus test but i
have a feeling it may be that way based
upon everything i'm hearing about how
prevalent these tests are going to be it
may be that way i mean band-aids are
prevalent now anytime you need a
band-aid you have one it's going to be
kind of like that and you're going to
get a box of coronavirus tests like you
get a box of band-aids i think that's
what it's going to be like come labor
day that's what makes it easier for the
nfl to play its games
yeah and and positivity and hope are not
a bad thing here that's really what what
i've been trying to preach i'm not uh
gonna gonna say you know
join the protests that are that are
getting out in front of everyone saying
we need to reopen the country right this
second but positivity and hope that the
nfl season will go as scheduled is not a
bad thing and i think that it's a lot
for a lot of people who uh love sports
this is what they kind of need to feel
like we're moving in the right direction
and these baby steps matter i've said it
before i just i need a pat on the back
every now and then saying hey you're
doing a good job by staying at home
positive reinforcement i'm like a dog
just give me that little pad on the top
of the head and i can keep i can keep
doing the tricks that you need me to
keep doing
and the balance is the last point on
this because i want to focus more on the
schedule today but the balance is
respecting the virus
and finding a way to coexist with it
not just run out the door and act like
it's fine right when i was a kid there
was a dog at the end of the street that
would have bit me if it could
and i knew how to co-exist with that dog
i knew how to stay away from that dog i
knew the dog was there i never acted
like the dog wasn't there and i got to a
point where i accepted it and the dog
and i had an understanding and i stayed
the hell away from the dog you can't
just act like the dog i i.e the virus
isn't there but there is going to be a
way to co-exist with the virus and the
nfl is confident we're going to be there
come september the chief schedule let's
look at this very briefly here the chief
schedule
has some great quarterback matchups
assuming everyone stays healthy and the
deeper we get into the season the more i
get concerned that one of these guys are
going to be injured but patrick mahomes
right out of the gates has deshawn
watson then two weeks later on monday
night football it's the latest meeting
between the chiefs and the ravens aka
mahomes and lamar jackson the last two
mvps it's a fight with tom brady week 12
in tampa bay that's a late afternoon
sunday game drew brees in new orleans
the chiefs have to go there and then
matt ryan the falcons quarterback goes
to kansas city week 16. so some great
great quarterback matchups on this chief
schedule but you know what i look at
each of these games
other than the trip to baltimore i feel
like these are games that the chief
should win
not that i'm predicting not not that i'm
predicting the outcomes of game to be
played months from now i don't know if
you have noticed any of this on my
twitter feed i have a very strong
aversion to the concept trying to figure
out what's going to happen with games
not going to be played until november or
december because a lot is going to
change between now and then but the
chiefs are good enough they're good
enough
in the abstract that
we should have confidence in them every
week just like you have confidence in
the bears every week
pick them pick them uh the other the
other games on the chief schedule that
we didn't even have up on that board
because we don't know who the starting
quarterback is but the chiefs will have
three games against teams that drafted
qb brethren in the first round they have
uh week two and week 15 or sorry week 17
against the chargers so we might see
justin herbert against patrick mahomes
sorry i'm all screwed up i haven't had
my coffee yet we also have tua in week
15 or 14 so you might see patrick holmes
versus the next class of quarterbacks in
two and justin
what's with not having herbert coffee
yet i'm surprised you haven't like you
can be grinding the beans on the air
grind the beans print uh do the french
press
um yeah i'm pouring my coffee whatever
you want dave all right that first that
first like seven minutes of this show
when i don't have my coffee ready you're
gonna see my brain just activate and
it's gonna be wild the things that i say
and how much of a hurt i put on mike
florio in whatever debate we're going to
get into
i'd rather you not have the coffee but i
like the little waft of steam it gives
it a very kind of a cozy feel on a
friday morning the steam is wafting up
from your french press um
yeah look
we always go into the season
assuming that the super bowl champion is
going to continue
to be a great great team and there's no
reason to think the super bowl champion
won't be right back there
and even with the patriots recent
dominance where they keep showing up in
the super bowl almost every year
um there still hasn't been back-to-back
champions since 2003-2004 when the
patriots did it so you know chances are
something's going to happen with the
chiefs at some point that that with all
those great teams that are coming after
them harder than ever it's going to be
harder for them to get back than it was
for them to get there in the first place
i try to always remind myself of that
but if they do we need to appreciate it
if they do get back we shouldn't get
bored by oh here are the chiefs again
getting back and winning it again is
herculean
and i i i i would not expect that to
happen and if it does we shouldn't be
upset about it we should celebrate it
no i don't think people would be bored
with the chiefs getting back to the
super bowl uh knowing like the average
fan i would say we have
a patch of two super bowls so so he's
already got one another super bowl for
patrick mahomes and then maybe a return
so a third uh super bowl game for him
before the general public decides they
randomly hate patrick mahomes because
he's too good it's the warriors effect
it happens it happens in all sports if a
team gets good for too long everyone
turns and says this isn't fun anymore we
don't like you so i i think he's still
got at least another super bowl win in
him before that changes
you could have said it's just it's the
chicago bulls effect why didn't you go
with with that too since it's good i'm
trying to go recent well yeah i mean
recent memory yeah i thought you just
didn't want to pick up i love michael
jordan no everyone still loved michael
jordan steph curry you know and kevin
durant and that whole thing happened and
people kind of turned on him
yeah i don't know that everyone still
loves michael jordan but that's a topic
for a different day i don't know i think
the last dance reveals more of the
underbelly than uh than uh maybe it
should and and it also hints that
there's a lot more there that they're
not telling us about
that's because you're the type of guy
that would probably quit if he was
michael jordan's teammate you can't take
that type of uh leadership
and bullying all right let's
take i take it from you every friday
that's true that's true i'm the michael
jordan of this show thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports